what do a t16 skyhopper toy imperial
inquisitors and the spice trade have in
common they're all easter eggs you
missed in obi-wan kenobi episodes one
and two warning spoilers ahead
obi-wan kenobi starts out in a flashback
set during revenge of the sith
specifically the brutal assaults on the
jedi temple led by anakin skywalker a
scene shows a class of jedi younglings
training with a master in the waves of
the force when clone troopers attacked
the class the master escorts her
students through the halls of the temple
taking down several attacking clone
troopers along the way tragically she
doesn't make it far before dying to a
well-placed blaster bolt leaving the
younglings to fend for themselves in
addition to showing the new angle on the
events of order 66 the flashback scene
includes a couple of details that most
fans of the star wars prequels should
recognize the helmets that the
younglings are wearing for instance are
the same ones worn by yoda's students in
attack of the clones the layouts of the
jedi temple as shown in the escape
sequence also perfectly mirrors his
portrayal and the prequel trilogy
finally the order 66 scene sets the
stage for the gross imbalance of power
rampant drone the imperial era some of
the younglings may have survived but
they would either become fugitives or
imperial inquisitors
what do we do now
we run
disney plus has returned to tatooine
again and again in his various star wars
shows and while obi-wan quickly makes
his way off the desert planet in his own
series he spends a whole first episode
wandering the dune sea at this point
jawas and panthers are a little too
commonplace to counter easter eggs but
there are still some fun details waiting
to be found the saloon that the
inquisitors infiltrate is a nice homage
to the mos eisley cantina complete with
bright green drinks served in tall
opaque glasses obi-wan's java friend
tikka references a gentleman wastes
which any good star wars fan knows are
not to be travelled lightly
additionally there's a good sampling of
the local tatooine wildlife
obi-wan earns a living by working on a
butcher line harvesting meat from the
massive corpse of what appears to be a
crate dragon or some similarly massive
beast his cruel overseer might conjure
memories of rey's portion paying bass in
the force awakens it's then revealed
that obi-wan's main mode of transport is
an eop a long-standed camel-like
creature first introduced in the phantom
menace eops have historically been best
known for their flatulence but obi-wan
seems to have required one with more
decorum
obi-wan kenobi episode 1 paints a pretty
grim picture of the jedi's life in exile
after a hard day at work he returns his
hideout in the desert which is little
more than a furnished cave still even
amid the barrenness obi-wan has retained
some reminders of his old life which
includes some interesting references to
the star wars movies at the entrance to
his home there's a periscope scanner
presumably a security protocol to alert
him to intruders fans may recognize the
device's design as an identical
periscope is used repeatedly by r2d2
throughout the star wars films hopefully
obi-wan's is simply a repurposed gadget
and not the appendage of some poor
astromech droid buried in the sun
later in episode 1 obi-wan takes out an
old hologram communicator to receive a
transmission from bail organa it's
another device that should be familiar
to those who have seen the movies as
obi-wan is seen using it in the prequel
trilogy perhaps most striking of all
however is the cloud of defeat that
follows obi-wan under his bend persona
the jedi truly looks like he's given up
he's buried his and anakin's lightsaber
in the desert in what is a possible
allusion to the end of the rise of
skywalker he's terrorized by nightmares
and he is hesitant to use the force in
basically any scenario given how calm
and controlled obi-wan is in a new hope
it's interesting to see him in such a
dark place
if you've absorbed much star wars media
in the disney era then you're probably
familiar with the imperial inquisitors
moses ingram's reaver who takes the
villainous lead in the disney plus
series is a new addition but some of the
emperor's agents have appeared in the
past sung kang's fifth brother for
instance has featured in several
previous projects including the darth
vader comics and star wars rebels he
eventually meets his end at the hands of
darth maul a curious twist to fate given
their shared history of hunting for
obi-wan the grand inquisitor another
prominent villain from the star wars
comics and star wars rebels also makes
his presence felt in the obi-wan show
however he's a bit different this time
around in star wars rebels the grand
inquisitor is voiced by jason isaacs and
some fans were upset when he was recast
with rupert friend for the live-action
version after being stabbed by reaver in
a surprising betrayal though the grand
inquisitor's fade seems up in the air
it's possible that he'll survive the
attack but it's also possible that
friend's character is a different
version of the villain and the isaac's
rendition in rebels might be some sort
of clone it is star wars after all
regardless both the fifth brother and
the grand inquisitor wield the same
spinning lightsabers first shown in star
wars rebels and they look a bit more
intimidating in live action
one of the more touching moments in
obi-wan kenobi episode 1 comes drawing
ben's interaction with tikka the jawa
he spends a good portion of his
hard-earned money to buy a toy for the
young luke skywalker and not just any
toy either specifically obi-wan
purchases a model of a t-16 skyhopper
a small airspeeder first mentioned in
the original star wars luke references
the craft during the briefing for the
first death star attack claiming that
but it's not impossible i used to
bullseye womp rats in my t-16 back home
he's also shown playing with a toy
version of the speeder during an early
conversation with c-3po it seems that
obi-wan was the giver of that gift all
along which is a fun little twist on a
tiny piece of pre-existing lore though
luke's uncle owen insists that obi-wan
takes the toy back it seems that he
acquiesces in the end
a lot of star wars media has dealt with
luke's time on tatooine but far less
time has been spent exploring his sister
leia's upbringing on old iran obi-wan
kenobi addresses that by spending time
on the planet following a ten-year-old
layer through the ins and outs of her
real life young star vivian lyra blair
does an excellent job bringing the young
princess to life
complete with leia's signature snark
stubbornness and wet in one scene while
climbing a tree with her little droid
friend lola leia starts naming the ships
she sees leaving the local spaceport
napoleon ranger probably scouting for
murson pirates
the mention of aquilian rangers is a
deep cut reference to the aquilae first
mentioned in an infamous cut line from
the original star wars the sun pirates
appear in some early star wars comics
that have since been relegated to the
legends timeline though they have also
been referenced in canonical media it's
also worth noting that in an attempt to
avoid her adoptive parents impending
political reception leia sends a young
decoy to be dressed and ornamented in
her place the exact same tactic her
mother padme used many times throughout
her political career
leia quickly reminds obi-wan of padme
after they meet and it's clear why
soon after arriving on the crime-ridden
world of daiyu obi-wan sees a face he
certainly didn't expect
that of an old clone trooper begging for
money on the side of a dirty street
though the former republic soldier is
technically much younger than obi-wan he
looks notably older as his body has
broken down due to the camino wins
accelerated aging alterations it's a
powerful reminder of what happened to
the clones after the rise of the empire
as shown in star wars the bad batch most
were quickly phased out of military
service it's clearly jarring for obi-wan
to see the old clone which makes sense
giving his complicated history with them
on the one hand he probably saw his old
friends cody and rex in the beggar's
face and he felt a deep sadness on the
other hand the events of order 66 would
surely have created a traumatic
connection to the clones obi-wan moves
on from the encounter quickly but it
surely stays with him especially since
the clone's blue accented armor is
remarkably similar to rex's
if there's underworld activity happening
in a star wars story there's a good
chance it has something to do with spice
the all-purpose drug signifier taken
straight from june that rule holds true
in obi-wan kenobi as well with the spice
trade rearing its head immediately on
dayu a young dealer tries to sell the
rogue jedi some of the stuff naming a
few different varieties including kessel
a primary space planet most famous for
the kessel run and felucian a reference
to the planet felucia where jedi ailer
sakura met her in fortune attend drawing
order 66. later on obi-wan infiltrates a
spice lab and even uses a vial of the
stuff to fend off a group of would-be
captors he smashes the small glass
container on the ground and locks his
attackers in with it sending them all on
what looks to be a pretty intense trip
less an easter egg than a fun little
detail this one's still worth mentioning
given the main character in the series
in the original star wars ben kenobi
describes lightsabers in an interesting
way an elegant weapon
for a more
civilized day
this line is referenced again in revenge
of the sith after obi-wan discards her
used blaster and declares it so
uncivilized
it's interesting then that he used his
blasters so prevalently in the first
couple of episodes of his own show as he
doesn't want to out himself as a jedi
obi-wan hesitates to use either the
force or his lightsaber he instead
relies on his martial arts prowess and
all weapons he can find to keep the bad
guys at bay more importantly obi-wan
doesn't complain once about the blasters
he's forced to use almost as if he's had
to let go of his old jedi pride it's a
small detail but it helps build the
sense that he's really given up all hope
if obi-wan kenobi can use a blaster
without a snide comment things truly
have taken a dark turn
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
obi-wan kenobi are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]